when the causes that people are behind
are more important to them than the
system the system is in Jeopardy and so
you see just even uh people moving from
place to place in terms of where they
think it's more uh sympathetic to their
way of being and what they're like you
know New York Chicago uh San Francisco
California moves to Texas and so on and
you're seeing um then
um not a not as much respect for the
Constitution and the legal system
because you have a win at all cost so
for example if you have the dispute
between
um let's say Disney and the Florida
governor in the past there would have
been almost mutual respect for different
points of view but what you now get back
is you get back to a power conflict well
you know what would the odds put I'll
ask you what you think the odds are uh
that for example in the next president
residential election that neither side
accepts losing you know I'd say almost
too close to call
um and what is the possibility that
states do not follow the directions of
the Supreme Court decisions because the
Supreme Court decisions can be viewed by
one side as a political decision made by
the other Supreme Court and how do we
get around that or whatever just like
Sanctuary cities in other words I will
not follow that rule and that and so now
you start to have a breakdown of the
system and you have power politics
determining things